I became interested in cereal grains not
even thinking about the fact that they
were sealed grains to me that was post
toasties and we teased and things like
that I'd been in building hotels in in
the food business for a long long time
and my mother was a ho today as well but
she had been raised in South Carolina in
aiken and on edisto island which is a
sea island just south of charleston
south carolina and i was raised in san
diego california with a lot of southern
cookin my mom is a black skillet cook
that's what she grew up on and she's
also what we call Geechee GE e CH AE
which means rice at every meal the first
pot on the stove in the morning is rice
and it's there all day long and my
surfing buddies when I was growing up
just thought that was the weirdest thing
in the world I took it all for granted
and then during college sort of started
sending my mother to back to San Diego
grits that I'd fine because I went to
school in North Carolina so fine grits
which are ground corn that's a staple
food in the southern part of the United
States found grits and occasionally I'd
air freight some greens back of offense
and really good collards and field peas
occasionally biscuit we specifically
gram flour because we were raised with
those traditions and she never really
liked anything I sent her and over the
course of me building hotels around the
u.s. and then narrowed it down to I
loved working in the south so I narrowed
it down to the south and narrowed it
down to the Virginia to Georgia coastal
corridor and then I finally walked away
from it I discovered that what my mother
had grown up on just wasn't there
anymore period there was no really fresh
milling of grits which is a food way
that's very important to the south and
its worldwide new crop rice hand pounded
by the fields and cooked immediately we
don't even have that in this country we
don't have a designation under the
USDA that I know of that says new crop
anything so the concepts gone my mother
remembered all that because during the
Depression in the south everybody was
growing and then hand milling their own
stuff they couldn't afford to do
anything else so if you want to gretsch
you had to grind him yourself on a hand
mill in the backyard and you had to grow
the corn or you weren't going to eat so
my mom being in the hotel business fed
more people out the back door in the
front door and the back door folks were
actually eating better than the front
door folks if my mom had anything to do
with it so that kind of hand food
directly out of the ground is what my
mother was looking for and when I sent
her these things back they were really
from the industrial age and they had no
connection to artisan foods or hand
foods or anything that would have to do
with fresh you know the idea of fresh
grains just as foreign today as a point
of food excellence fresh milled cereal
grains if you want to get technical
convey a much greater flavor profile
than grains that are aged up unless you
know what you're doing and you can
actually take the aging philosophies
that happen in the near eastern rim all
the way through Eurasia and off into
China and in the islands Japan Korea if
you look at how those food preservation
systems work with grains that was
actually being done in the south as well
and is now gone my mother actually knew
about that too so aged rice have new
crop rice on this side being grown right
where she was on Edisto Island in little
patches and hand pounded fresh for the
table every day so they knocked the
halls off with a mortar and hand pound
system winnow off the hulls and that
rice would be table rice and then they
were also aging rice and that came from
saving seed so my mother was involved in
all of that and never warmed to anything
I sent her so I got into Anson Mills
because as we opened these historic
hotels that I was working on we needed
periods
Pacific dinners for the architecture of
the hotels most of them were federal
national saw a few Georgian period
architecture so we looked for meals that
were indigenous and also matched that
period and started doing food history
research and as I became more and more
interested in how that worked and how my
mother wasn't being satisfied with the
things I said her I realized that we
just weren't growing and or producing
foods like that anymore so I decided to
do it that's the short story
my mother was my main consultant so I
mailed a lot of corn that i sourced all
over the place because i figured if i
started with grits i could make it to
rice because i'm a rice person and I
wanted to do rice but I knew it was nigh
on impossible no one was really growing
rice for any reason but small research
and or hunting in South Carolina when I
started Anson Mills the concept actually
started in the early 90s by actually
found it Anson Mills in 1998 so all
during the time between the early 90s
and 1998 I was actually look looking for
corn I ended up chasing down bootleggers
those are people who make liquor illicit
lay in the hills and valleys and
out-of-the-way places in the south and
particularly in South Carolina we have
some hot spots in the center of the
state and then out towards the coast and
certainly in the mountains I was
fascinated with what my mother told me
she thought would be the best grits came
from the coastal areas of the Carolinas
so I started looking for bootleggers
along the coastal regions and found one
who was completely off the grid had
tractor powered mills in the middle of
nowhere on vast farms with corn and
wheat and everything else growing
forever this this family had been at it
since the 1600s they were on the local
church register and so they'd retained
every one of their food ways they were
still making all their own jams growing
grapes and making their own wine growing
their own corn making on grits and
making them liquor growing their own
weed and making phenomenal gram biscuits
from new crop weed out of the field and
they had different foods for different
seasons of crop harvest all year long
and everything was intertwined and
everything grew together so you didn't
have field peas as field peas you'd have
field peas and corn together in the same
field you didn't grow just wheat you
grow wheat that would say 30 inches tall
and then you may be grow ri'eb of it
that's seven feet tall harvest the Rye
first cut it high then you cut low for
the week then they
clover down here at the bottom or winter
peas or whatever all these are winter
crops so nobody was growing any one
thing in one field and I first saw that
I went you can't machine this and he
said why would we want a machine this
this is eaten food this is not we're not
selling this off for animals this is
what we this is our kitchen food and
it's the first time I'd hurt anyone else
talk in reality about what my mother had
always said about kitchen gardens and
kitchen fields and so I stayed with that
family a long time and they gave me the
starting corn that I started Anson Mills
with which is a gourd seed which just
means dense but it's dint of a period
when we didn't do a whole lot to Native
American corn so it's not much removed
from what corn was thereupon first
contact and in that particular way we
discovered the rediscovered the ideas of
new crop rediscovered the ideas of fresh
milling which we knew were there but no
one was doing it and decided that
there's got to be a way to distribute
this and kind of violate the rules so
instead of the 20 mile radius we picked
as our kitchen population the best chefs
in America which is more like a boutique
winery and that's how Anson Mills came
about
the only environment we were interested
in is whether we were going to like the
food I mean a lot whether it was going
to be remarkable you know we predicated
everything only on flavor and from
flavor which you send something to a
chef that they've had and all of a
sudden they're having an epiphany those
I've never tasted it like this before
started with flavor everything else came
from it and came from it easily there's
not one new advanced except for trying
to limit diesel that I can think over
the last decades since i've been doing
this now 12 years that i wasn't already
doing just because we wanted flavor
flavor equals nutrition in landrace
plant and animal systems if you don't
have remarkable flavor the nutrition is
not there that's how hunter-gatherers
worked you know taste it then make it
taste better and if it tastes better
it's better for you that's a that's a
fundamental from antiquity for all of
mankind